(gentle violin music)
- Traditional Hasidic music
is based on words of prayer.
It has a certain sadness to it.
But my music is different.
♪ Instead of searching Google, ♪
♪ I'm busy making Kugel ♪
("Hang Up the Phone" by Lipa Schmeltzer)
I was the first one with
the whole Hasidic outfit,
that come from a very
close-minded community,
who went to do crazy
shows with crazy outfits.
("Hang Up the Phone" by Lipa Schmeltzer)
I've been called the Hasidic Lady Gaga.
I've been called the Jewish Elvis.
But I promise you, I
would rather be just Lipa.
(intense techno music)
This is the house I grew up.
Twelve children in this house.
I was born in New Square,
a religious orthodox,
very close-minded community.
We had no radio, no television,
there's only one rabbi, one synagogue,
one girls' school, one boys' school.
I barely left the community.
I was having a hard time as a child,
and traditional Hasidic
music was something
that gave me an outlet.
(singing)
I only did Hasidic music originally,
so I started to perform only at weddings.
That was my dream, to be a wedding singer.
I had to be 21 years old when I heard
my first non-Jewish song.
I started working for the
butcher in the fish store,
so I put the radio on.
And I think the first song was
♪ I need to know, ohhh I need to know ♪
♪ Tell me baby girl,
'cause I need to know. ♪
And that opened up a whole world to me.
♪Sorry, gotta go party,
so you can join me ♪
♪ In my Ferrari, hey! ♪
(funky beat)
Listening to sexy music, I had a chance
and discovered there's a different way
of composing lyrics and composing music.
So when I started writing lyrics,
the lyrics that I used were new.
My music was advancing towards hip-hop,
R&B, and American modern music.
My music has, had many
reactions throughout the years.
Many rabbis tried to stop me.
Everything that's new can make some people
who live in a fanatic
system, can make them mad.
But many good people,
even rabbis, love me,
and they recognize that
this is God-given talent,
and they don't let me stop.
I was privileged to
perform in crazy places,
I did one show even with Jay Leno!
I did Madison Square Garden.
I've made music videos that
have millions of views.
I've recorded probably, 19 albums or so.
I'm never stopping until
God will say, “Lipa is done.”
(intense techno music)
I have many times, I was
thinking to drop out completely
from the Hasidic community, just run away.
But this is where I
was born, this is where
my heritage is, this is
where my upbringing is.
And it's a smarter move to
take this and modernize it.
I try to take Hasid and then open it up.
It's a beautiful thing to open the mind.
(inhales loudly)
I think.